a development plan
that will help really improve people's lives,
while protecting that precious global asset
that is the Amazon Rainforest.
And this is just the beginning,
You can create a Social Progress Index
for any state, region, city or municipality.
We all know and love TEDx;
this is Social Pogress-x.
This is a tool for anyone to come and use.
Contrary to the way we sometimes talk about it,
GDP was not handed down from God on tablets of stone. (Laughter)
It's a measurement tool invented in the 20th century
to address the challenges of the 20th century.
In the 21st century,
we face new challenges:
aging, obesity, climate change, and so on.
To face those challenges,
we need new tools of measurement,
new ways of valuing progress.
Imagine if we could measure
what nonprofits, charities,
volunteers, civil society organizations
really contribute to our society.
Imagine if businesses competed
not just on the basis of their economic contribution,
but on their contribution to social progress.
Imagine if we could hold politicians to account
for really improving people's lives.
Imagine if we could work together —
government, business, civil society, me, you —
and make this century the century of social progress.
Thank you.
(Applause)